ما الذي يستمع إليه البالغ من العمر ثلاثين عامًا إلى
أغنية بعنوان punk-rock princess ،
سأقوم بتسمية موسيقى بيضة CNN الخاصة بي كل يوم تعلمون أنه
يسجل كل يوم ، لا تعمل الأزرار
فعليًا ، لذا يجب أن أقوم
بتحطيمها لذا هذا  هي ساعة سوني القديمة ، إنها
ساعة منبه لعام 2008 ، إنها قذرة
ومغطاة بأشياء فاضحة لم أنظفها مطلقًا
، لذا اشتريت هذه الساعة عن
قصد لتجنب استخدام هاتفي الخلوي
بالقرب من سريري ، فهواتفنا جيدة جدًا
في كل شيء في الثانية التي
تختارها  لقد حوصرت فيه تمامًا ، مثل
أي شيء يمكن أن يوجهك بعيدًا عن هذه
الدورة التدريبية ، يكون مفيدًا
لماذا يستثمر شخص ما في
السجلات المادية لديه حوالي 300 منهم في المنزل
وهو أمر غير عملي في الواقع
، لقد كنت أجمعهم منذ أن كان عمري
حوالي 16 عامًا
قديمًا ورثت مجموعة من والدي من ذلك
ولكن في الكلية اعتدت أن أعمل دي جي إذا
فتحتها ، لدي بعض الصور الرائعة التي تعرف
أشياء لا يمكنك الحصول عليها حقًا عندما
تستمع إليها على منصات البث ،
أعتقد ذلك  السبب الرئيسي
لاستنباط في الواقع  st in vinyl هي جودة الصوت التي
تستمع بها إلى الموسيقى على أسطوانة فينيل
هي أقرب ما يمكن أن تحصل
عليه في الاستوديو ، والاستماع إلى
ما يتم تسجيله ، قد يكون هناك
الكثير من مشغلات Tetris هناك الذين يشعرون
بالإهانة الشديدة من  كنت دائمًا
أدفع جميع عربات ماريو وما زلت
ألعب كثيرًا مع الأصدقاء ،
كان في الواقع يخرج مع فتاة ذات
مرة كنا نعيش في أجزاء مختلفة
من البلد ، كنا نلعب Wii Mario
Kart ضد بعضنا البعض ثم في ذلك
الوقت  هذه هي الأداة الأكثر سخونة في
المدينة ، والسبب الذي جعلني أبقيت هذا هو
أنني كنت خاسرًا تامًا في المدرسة
الثانوية وكنت أذهب إلى الخارج ، وهي تحتوي على
جميع قوائم التشغيل التي
أحبها أصدقائي والأولاد الذين أحببتهم والأولاد الذين  أعجبني بقائمة
التشغيل التي صنعوها من أجلي
وأعتقد أن هذا ما يجعلني متأكدًا حقًا من أنه
يمكنني الحصول على كل هذه
الأغاني على Spotify ، وبالتأكيد يمكنني إعادة إنشاء
كل قائمة تشغيل ،
لكن هذا كثير من العمل ، أرى نفسي
أستخدم هذه التقنية في 10 سنوات  نعم، أنا
يعني أعتقد ذلك ، لذا لا أعتقد أن الهواتف
ستذهب بعيدًا ولا أعتقد أنني
سأكون أقل إدمانًا على هاتفي أو أكثر
قدرة على الاستيقاظ بطريقة عادية ،
سيكون الاستماع إلى الموسيقى أكثر ملاءمة
منصات البث لكنها في
الحقيقة لا تقترب من
تجربة الاستماع إلى الموسيقى على
الفينيل لذلك أنا متأكد من أنني
سأستخدمها في غضون 10 سنوات لأنني أمتلكها لفترة
طويلة ربما تكون مثل واحدة
من  قطع من التكنولوجيا التي ما زلت أستخدمها
موجودة في هاتفي ، لذا لم أستطع رؤية
دائمًا سوقًا لأشياء مثل
هذا الشيء يفعل شيئًا واحدًا ويفعله
بشكل مناسب حتى أنه يشبه نوعًا ما معطلاً
ولكنه لا يزال يؤدي وظيفته الرئيسية
و  إنه جيد إنه جيد تمامًا 5 نجوم